(swoosh)
(upbeat music)
- Talk to us, Evan, please
a little bit about the book,
Your One Word, how did
that idea come to fruition?
Like was it something you'd
been planning all along
or were you just one day like
I'm going to write a book,
let's make this happen?
- I never wanted to write a book.
It wasn't my thing.
My agent Steve in New York
is like we need a book, you need a book.
I need a book to sell
you into corporations
and all this stuff.
Like, I don't want a book, Steve.
Look at my YouTube channel.
I can open up doors.
It's not 1950 anymore, right?
Like you don't need a
book to open up doors.
- Yes, sir.
- I mean, he's like okay,
I'm going to pitch you
anyway into publishers.
I'm like, do whatever,
pitch me, it doesn't matter.
And then through that process
I was figuring out my one word, believe.
I started branding my
business around believe.
My website was about believe.
My newsletters were about believe.
I was making videos about believe.
Everything that was believe related
took off way more than anything else.
And so, and one because it's
easy to understand and market
but two, it was like, it was more me.
Believe is not just a marketing thing.
It's authentic for me.
It's what I am.
And so, it's curious to
then find other businesses.
Like I'm going to do this crazy thing
and build my entire
business around one word.
It sounds nuts.
And then I started finding other
businesses that had done it
and from the guy who just built
a $50,000 full-time income for himself
around one word, to then a business
that had half a million
dollars, a million dollars,
five million dollars, and 150
million dollars in revenue.
And I went out to interview these people
and they all just figured it out.
Nobody had a blueprint.
There was no plan,
and so I thought it would be pretty cool
if there was a plan.
Like if there's a book
that I want to write,
that's the book I want to write,
not this other stuff that
you guys are pitching me.
And so, I was really
reluctant at the start.
I like didn't want to do it at all
and I was just following my agent,
and like didn't want to take calls,
and didn't want to do like,
we'd take a call and
then give us a propose.
I'm like a don't want to do a proposal.
I don't even want to do a book.
But then when this idea came,
I'm like guys, this is
it, this is the thing.
And they hated it at the start.
They're like, that's a workbook,
that's like five pages of a worksheet.
Like, are you kidding me?
This is more than a book,
this is a series.
And they're like for a book
they want like 60,000 words.
That's how much like a
typical book is going to be.
I wrote 120,000 words.
- Oh God.
- We cut half the book.
We cut an entire book,
and they're like oh, we
can use that as volume two.
I'm like no, no, no, I'm like,
we're not even keeping it,
I'm throwing that away.
Like, if I write another book,
it'll be something different.
It's like just grind out the work
and I'll throw away more
than what most people
will even create
and so, like that's the
best of the 120,000 words
condensed down to 60 or
65 or whatever it is.
I just got really excited
about being able to teach
the concept and I thought
it would actually lend
itself better to a book
because of the activities and exercises,
than making YouTube videos.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
Thank you to the guys from VNR Media
for the awesome interview.
The full link is in the description below
if you want to check it out.
I'd love to know what did you think?
What are your thoughts?
Leave them in the comments below.
I'm simply curious to find out.
Finally, I want to give a
quick shout out to Dan Khaul.
I hope I pronounced that okay.
Dan, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, I really,
really, really appreciate it,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So, thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is
much love.
I'll see you soon.
(swoosh)